in effetti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fatti jake e viaggi giocherò
ad occhi chiusi perché sono capaci io di
fare le cose ad occhi chiusi
ho vinto sì e siamo tornati sud da snai
e grecia vi avevo promesso che avrei
provato a fare la hard versioni those
like trains perché nello scorso episodio
sono arrivato alla terza notte mi sono
detto ma perché non fare la cosa che più
difficile ancora giacché navi a scappare
con la normale non fanno un cazzo di
piega ragazzi fantastico non fa conti mi
fa continuare alla notte tre io sono
convinto che in modalità difficile non
faccio neanche la notte uno ma voi mango
alla prima però vabbè dai proviamoci lo
stesso allora germain semi capezzoli
in teoria dovrebbe farmi di partire da
zero perché la difficoltà è diversa ma
siccome senes trasmette il calcio va beh
mi sembra che ripartiamo dalla terza
notte sarà una passeggiata ragazzi
giochi che inviando scavo centro è
andato mamma non so se avete visto il
primo episodio di dido sneijder ricerche
ho fatto ma sono stato veramente bravo
quindi sono sicuro che non avrà
assolutamente problemi a vincere anche
questa
ciao zio a quanto siete beh intanto non
c'è nessuno ce ne sono due dovrebbero
essere in quattro senshan 2 fantastico è
meglio che muovo il culo vediamo
qualcuno e chi non lo sapesse ragazzi
c'è questa tendina che si chiude pian
piano dobbiamo fare attenzione che non
si apra completamente perché sennò ce
l'ha nel culo non è un problema ragazzi
in teoria perché tanto mi ammazzeranno
prima gli altri quindi no problem però
già che ci sono la chiudo porca [ __ ]
quanto e ansiolitico la modalità
difficile non è soltanto più difficile
sono anche più brutti vizi gli
animatronica tana [ __ ]
ma dove cazzo uscito questo ne ho
neanche visto ma io posso correre solo
in
quello ancora capito se un bagno
qualcosa che sta roba
tanto c'è del sangue sulla tendina ici
se chiudo proprio le porte così a caldo
sulla fiducia è cosa ho chiuso chiuso
solo quella ragazzi non so quanto possa
servirmi sinceramente provo per te l'ho
chiusa la porta che cazzo
non capisco i giochi mi girano le palle
sentite ragazzi è diventato impossibile
facciamo che sarti new game e ci
togliamo la sto pensiero senza pensieri
già la notte uno non riuscirà a farla
almeno partiamo dalla prima non dalla
terza organica è impossibile ma solo una
porta alla volta si può chiudere a sta
cosa non la sapevo
quindi io posso credere.ho una o l'altra
la z e quella sinistra che sarebbe
quella dove è spuntato il tizio giusto
perfetto importante è capire come
funziona base meno se spunta qualcuno
non ci caga l'amico e chi è che ha riso
a due domande avrei ancora uno chi cazzo
è che arride ogni tanto che mi sento
ridere sotto motivo proprio prima cosa
la seconda cosa è e cosa serve questo
ma serio che cosa serve la scrivania
ecco perché mi dovrò infilare sotto la
scrivania o forse la prima forse la
prima notte posso farcela
forse ma forse anche no
e ancora non ho capito perché c'è
qualcuno nel bagno che cosa minchia ci
fai nel mio cesso la bellezza di sto
gioco che puoi muovere la torcia ragazzi
non mi ricordo se avevo già fatto vedere
ma è troppo figo o come lo pigli al
culetto mi spiace zio è promise brutto
che te devo dì ma come faccio a sapere
se n'è andato dal cazzo ma che casino
non ne vedo neanche uno dovrebbe essere
in 4 non ne vedo len che uno bellissimo
ok la tenda la tenda la tenda a tenda
[ __ ] la tenda veloce è bravo
bravissimo
la minuti e di mi.fi che mi spieghi come
si gioca lo so come si gioca a togliere
non lo so come si gioca non ho capito
mio mouse è diventato rosa dalla
carriera ragazzi non riesco a fare
neanche la prima notte come cazzo si può
farla quella terza la cui va la quinta
poi perché c'è solo 5 pensate
soprattutto perché io continua giocato
ma se stai zitto devi morire e va dalla
[ __ ] dove sono gli altri perché non
c'era
una notte ce la posso fare una [ __ ]
notte una sola noi ti sto chiedendo
chissà cosa se gli spuntassero con
cognizione sarebbe anche più semplici
cioè non sarebbe possibile almeno ma
miss puntano a caso ora che non c'è
nessuno alle porte e allora cosa non tre
fermi dovete neanche a finire la frase
buco zero dove è andato dove è andato
terrore il fratello dove sei
dov'è adesso non lo dovete spiegare dove
è andato lo chiedo a voi perché non è
possibile
qua chiudo ci dovesse andato la vecchia
parte che non è possibile tutto sparisce
location strisce nicchia che che chi che
anzi è inutile se n'è andato bravo una
quota abbiamo scampato è passata un'ora
e deve morire il cugino naturalmente
c'era qualcuno che non ho visto ma
meglio così guardate quanto siamo mentre
ma che chiarite perché c'è qualcuno che
deve ridere ha già dimenticato questo
siamo quasi alle 4 di notte ai ragazzi
forse c'è speranza forum un aspetto a
farmi controllare se c'è qualcuno
davanti prima veloce però veloce cui
devo uscire non è che posso puntare la
torcia e guardano devo uscire solo
puntare la torcia gennaio che bussa non
ti apro un cazzo te ne devi star lì devi
morire e 5 sennò c'è veloci e cazzo dai
che sto vincendo regata e zio power user
giusta metà non quanto manca felice 18
secondi 16 16 secondi 16 secondi dai dai
dai dai dai prego farò qualsiasi cosa
adottare un bambino sano fare jogging la
mattina andrò aiutare le vecchiette
datano sarà la strada ma ti prego fallo
di sei qualcuno che lo figlia al culetto
non so come ho fatto non ne ho idea ma
dopo 0 ma va bene così tra scollegata
dall'energia perché avevo tenuto la
porta troppo chiusa e mi è andata di
culi stimo ma di culo in una maniera
incredibile
tutti lì a tutti quanti insieme senti
complimenti
lui non ce l'ha il fiatone proprio credo
e non ne sono sicuro la chiosa ragazzi
va bene così va bene sono contento fotte
sei case sto morto tanto non ce la farò
mai a farah notte due ho vinto una notte
sola ma fa pianista modalità va più che
bene sono contento a vita è stato
impossibile prova avevo promesso che
avevo proprio avevo promesso che l'avrei
fatto un laico voglio vedere i live che
esplode il mi piace non solo perché ho
vinto non so come ma va bene cosa in sé
l'episodio argomento non mi piace anche
a pochi minuti dal kitsch ammesse non
sono presenti screti ci vediamo al
prossimo vita e ragazzi